great design leads to great business
performance
and we have the numbers to show it
regardless of your company's goal
your business is ultimately centered
around your customers and users
and this is what design is all about
user centricity in
your business strategy processes and
products and services
at design singapore council we believe
that design is key to helping uncover
new business opportunities
and drive profitable and desirable
human-centered innovation
and design is not an abstract concept
for the first time mckinsey design has
successfully quantified business
improvements
from design and that's why we have
partnered them on the business value of
design program
an extensive five-year study by mckinsey
design found that high performing
companies
in design achieved higher revenue and
total returns to shareholders
by 32 and 56 respectively competitive
peers
built on mckinsey design's research the
business value of design
program helps your company understand
your design capabilities today
reimagine your aspirations for tomorrow
and identify actionable next steps
forward
the bvod program is structured into two
phases
in the first phase assess and reflect
your company will assess its current
design performance
and learn about the key design behaviors
most strongly correlated with improved
business performance
[Music]
in the next aspire and act phase you
will re-imagine the possibilities for an
upcoming business plan
and using insights gathered from your
company's assessment
develop an action plan to drive better
[Music]
performance
design is not an intangible concept it
is a key business enabler that looks
into every organization's ability to
harness
data and analytics about their business
how they shape
cross-functional talents helps them
focus on delivering holistic user
experience
and the need to for continuous iteration
as they bring new products and services
to market
we got introduced to mckinsey or this
program
by design singapore and then mckinsey
walked us through the mdi
framework that they use and that really
sort of helped us benchmark ourselves
compared to
other peers in the industry the design i
think will be a
huge enabler to our growth design needs
to be fundamental to any
organization and i think that thinking
process that mindset that you have
through that growth trajectory that
you're about to embark on i think
especially for smes
since we are small and we need to be
quite nimble i think it's important to
align
everyone to make sure that we can scale
up that we can
grow internationally and and continue
with that growth mindset
and and really having the design-centric
approach to
any kind of future projects that we
embark on
today i've learned that as a company we
need to
open our mindset to not just the daily
tasks that's given but also in terms of
how we can move forward together
and also think about the customers
element first
and how we design and integrate together
as a whole
i think one of the main benefits for the
mdi is
to put that design thinking to the
forefront
of our activities so whereas it was
something that was sort of always on our
minds
this sort of pushes it in a structural
way
one of the things that we've learned to
stay agile is
to develop a common platform lingo
or model that we can use with the team
in order to track
consumer feedback in a continuous manner
you